je quittais mon grand amour la mv grâce
à laquelle j'avais remporté 13 titres
mondiaux
mais j'avais compris que le moment de
changer était arrivé
les moteurs à deux temps s'impose est
très rapidement
dames physio cette décision un site à
l'écurie a quitté la catégorie 350 pour
se concentrer sur celle qui sera la
dernière évolution du moteur
507 moto propulsé par un 4 temps en
ligne incliné de 10° atteint une
puissance de 102 chevaux à 14 1600 tours
et permis à phil read de conquérir en
1974 le dernier titre mondial pour l'
usine de cascina cost
quand le compte à augusto m'avait
proposé de courir avec la mv agusta
bien évidemment il s'agissait d'une
proposition fantastique que je n'aurais
jamais refusé
à cette époque-là augusta était la
ferrari du motocyclisme
grand pilote rend non du passé john
surtees mchale good guy hopkin
et bien sûr dia comeau agostini aussi
il s'agissait d'une équipe unique et
donc je les remerciais de m'accueillir
et de bien me payer je crois que à
l'époque je n'avais pas compris
l'importance de leurs propositions pas
pour le public mais plutôt pour
l'entreprise
en tout cas mon premier souci était de
gagner les compétitions
et d'aider le team manager le grand art
tour au manning à concevoir des motos de
plus en plus performantes
sont dans la saison je fis les
propositions concernant les freins qui
devait être plus légers afin de rendre
les virages de la moto plus rapide
je dois avouer que phil read qui était
un vrai anglais se comportait en
véritable gentleman
mais il était aussi très fort sur sa
moto
giacomo agostini passe à al ayyam à une
moto très compétitive et qui avait tout
le soutien technique de la maison de
production
et naturellement giacomo a été un grand
adversaire
quand agostini termina sa carrière je
courus contre garneau sarine haine qui
conduisait une yamaha mais je pense que
c'était avant l'arrivée de agostini chez
yamaha
yano sarine n était un grand pilote
contre lequel j'ai fait une compétition
fantastique en allemagne à hockenheim
mais je les battues
c'est vrai que cette fois-là sa chaîne
ce cas ça mais moi je sais que j'aurais
gagné quoi qu'il arrive
cette saison là fut très dur parce
qu'ils avaient de grands pilotes et que
parfois la moto yamaha était meilleure
phil read est arrivé chez nous traiteur
quelques années avant le passage de
agostini chez yamaha
c'était un pilote plein d'énergie est
très capable
il a remporté sept ou huit titres
mondiaux avec des motos d'écurie privé
autant 1963 ont participé à une
compétition dans la catégorie 500
centimètres cubes à trois cylindres
on avait les freins à tambours
et après de nombreux tours comportant
des lignes droites la poignée de frein
reculait et nous on priait pour que la
moto freina
la fin de la saison j'ai dit arturo
manic l'on avait besoin de freins à
disques car les japonais étaient déjà en
train de les utiliser ce maniement
demanda de chercher ce type de frein et
finalement je trouvais ces freins à
disques en aluminium très léger avec des
disques en magnésium produit par une
entreprise américaine est adaptée aux
dimensions de la mv
grâce à ces freins la moto tourner plus
rapidement sans que la poignée de frein
recul en nous permettant de nous arrêter
plus tard et plus rapidement
et
n'ayant ni ses teintes dans les années
70 en plus de giacomo agostini et de
phil read un autre pilote italien courte
pour mv agusta gianfranco bonnaire il
faut
courir pour mv était l'objectif de tous
les pilotes mais peu d'entre eux
bénéficier de ce privilège
moi j'ai eu cette chance aussi parce que
j'avais déjà démontré que j'allais très
fort et j'ai remplacé agostini quand il
passe à al ayyam a
porta les couleurs de la mv agusta
à partir de 1974 avec comme coéquipier
phil read
phil read avait déjà remporté quatre
titres mondiaux donc j'ai couru contre
mon coéquipier phil read contre giacomo
agostini contre barry sheene théoule
late show au lit et d'autres encore
cette année fut riche de succès
important en fin d'année bonera remporta
le titre de champion du monde dans la
catégorie 500 à cette époque là il y
avait un véritable esprit sportif on
était adversaires dans les compétitions
mes amis en dehors j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui cet esprit sportif a
disparu personnellement je garde de bons
souvenirs de ses années de course neil
milanais en 1976 le rideau est tiré sur
l'époque légendaire des courses de la mv
agusta
après la mort de domenico agusta
l'équipe à continuer à exister grâce à
notre enthousiasme
mais n'avions plus les moyens financiers
pour construire des motos capables de
rivaliser avec celle des japonais et
leur nouvelle technologie
après avoir dominé sur tous les circuits
du monde avec ses 270 grand prix et ses
75 titres arc-en-ciel laventure sportiva
boost a pris fin elle avait été voulue
et poursuivie pendant plus de trente
années par la famille agusta
la production des motos routières
les années 40 les modèles fabriqués
pendant cette décennie sont généralement
de petite cylindrée et possède un moteur
2 temps
il s'agit de la 98 turismo mousseau
historique et de la 125 turismo luceau
toutes les deux honnête et fiable mais
conçu pour une utilisation citadine
on
les années 50
y modèle i10 cuesta des cadets à limite
si elles en sont au début les modèles
fabriqués pendant cette décennie ne sont
pas très différents des modèles produits
jusqu'à cette époque là la cylindrée se
stabilise sur les 125 centimètres cubes
de la célèbre 125 4 temps dénommée cento
milla et sur les 175 centimètres cubes
de l'autre célèbre 175 css disco volante
son nom comme le moteur est toujours
deux temps
il s'agit toutefois de modèles citadins
et parmi ceux-ci la 125 pullman de 1953
se distingue avec sa ligne originale et
ses pneus à grande section
m
les années 60
dans la seconde moitié des années 60 mv
agusta introduit une innovation
technologique importante le moteur 4
temps coûteux et sophistiquée
le modèle 600 cm culte tourisme en 4
cylindres et 5 vitesses est lancé sur le
marché il atteint une vitesse maximum de
185 kilomètres heure
l'année suivante de nouvelles solutions
sont adoptées dans le domaine du design
et l'on conçoit la nouvelle 250 4 temps
à deux cylindres tourisme un modèle
prestigieux ayant remporté un très grand
succès
où
les années 70 dans les années 70 tout le
monde rêve de nouvelles 4 cylindres
digne héritier routière des mv agusta
elle avait gagné tous les grands prix
l'a350 sport hypothèses y voit le jour
elle atteint 165 km
in coistia durant ces années on commence
à produire avec un certain retard la
splendide 754 sinan sport avec une
transmission par cardan elle un
caractère esthétique franchement
engageant et atteint plus de 200 km
monde
yoda la production s'achève avec le
dernière quatre cylindres la fabuleuse
750 4 cylindres america
les scooters
étant donné le succès que la baisse pas
et la lambretta connaissent dans ces
années 50 mv agusta décide elle aussi de
réaliser une série de scooter nasser et
des sports peps et rata du monde il
s'agit de modèles intéressants qui
toutefois n'arrive pas à entamer la
suprématie de piaggio dino zanotti
il prit modèle est
le premier modèle est le 125 c est celle
de 1950
après lui il y aura d'autres modèles
tous équipés du moteur 125 2 temps
pour
la production reprend dans les années 60
avec le chico 160 qui ne fut pas une
grande réussite
et
d'eau pour la clausura d'être mv agusta
le dernier rapt après la fermeture du
secteur moto en 1977 on n'entend plus
parler de la célèbre usine de cascina
costa pendant plusieurs années après une
longue pause les frères castiglioni
propriétaire du groupe k qui va de
varèse reprennent la marque et décide de
l'utiliser pour une nouvelle 750 à 4
cylindres 1 très haute performance
produite par ce même groupe
cette moto super sportive dénommé f4 et
conçu par massimo tamburini
responsable du service de recherche
cagiva de san marino
la f4 et présenté en 1998 et pendant
toutes les années 2000 sera la moto
sportive la plus convoitée par les
passionnés
à côté de celle ci qu'on produit la
série brutale 750 qui n'est que la
version sans karen de la f4
mais elle doit müller en 2008 la mv
agusta est cédé par le groupe cagiva à
la maison américaines harley davidson
avec ses 75 titres mondiaux ses marques
ses pilotes 270 grand prix 3027 victoire
dans différentes disciplines la marque
mv agusta qui s'est aussi affirmé dans
le domaine de la production en série de
modèles innovants exclusif est beau est
devenu une légende
elle peut s'honorer d'avoir l'histoire
la plus fascinante du motocyclisme
mondiale
par la guerre aux plaintes
ils m'ont tous les noms ville d'art et
côté sonia doré et d'icônes et faut
évidemment chénier voir macbook toffoli
m
la boutique du feu
mais
là
les au sénat
ok
g
voilà
jean fournet
pardon
stade hélitas
j'y mets un communiqué
fr ou 6 mai
et à
m
le m
ça
champion sous des rochers
paris
la reggina
elle a alors et nombre d'ont
coli
suite